welcome to this video playing mr. Boris
from the UK platon before i have i have
this window white oops this was too much
I have this window had this window
closed with the statistics wanted to
check I want two times and played one
draw against the sky okay The Kings
Indian let's go with with h3 one of my
lines yeah come on let's play play it in
a boring boring way don't feel like a
complicated game so much ok let's see I
can play many moves here rook e8 is the
most conservative one c6 yep also
possible rookie eight long castles is
wise point rupee five group d 8 so
normally am black goes um night a 6 cm
taking some time curious Nadia 3 is not
the only move but this is the one that I
have had analyzed while ago the point is
that this is not so easy or at least
much trickier than it looks if he takes
only four 94 94 and so on looking for at
the end this rook t8 Bishop f8 bishop
age six and white is winning so he has
to play h6 basically the unless he wants
to play it as a complete sacrifice you
can try that just play a five or
something like that but then I go f3 and
keep the pawn which is not completely
clear but h6 is the normal move after
which white can take and keep the pawn
but this is quite I'm quite a big
concession to give up the dark squared
Bishop HC bishops f6 Bishop f6 is quite
good for black interesting yam him he
didn't he didn't play h6 after age 60 I
just retreat to e3 and now I'm just
keeping the pawn so this is as mentioned
not entirely clear but it shouldn't be
um quite enough compensation ok is it
ff5 maybe maybe you can go at five
yeah not sure I don't want to spend so
much time and spoiler this time
advantage it's quite nice to have in
this end game I really think yeah I
thought I final freedom maybe this year
this is an interesting way to play I
don't want to take ready the Sun as
mentioned quite a bit concession I can
play before I can play before this is
quite quite good am this is not where
you want to go to e6 so just just
complete development now f5 i can simply
take maybe i should have considered to
play g4 even yeah but not really
necessary taking oh yeah c5 this is a
good move making it a bit difficult
technically
yeah he's got this 94 idea okay I try
try to activate the bishop on f3 so on
f5 f5 and the idea is to play if I've
myself if if possible under only good
circumstances not sure
and is gained some play he really has
gained some play here that's quite quite
nice to see that I'm still ahead on the
clock okay maybe I can with this with
this I can take on d5 of course yeah
that's that's stupid really stupid chess
it can just uh 95 my intention was to
threaten 97 and rook takes D forward you
can of course simply take it you can
simply take it okay maybe this one but
not the plan not the original plan but
still the idea is to go 95 takes 95 yeah
yeah
c4 okay for them I want to play active
active moves active active players more
important rugby 5 rupee one is my idea
and then quickly activate the King f6 i
think is the good is the right move okay
this I like being a being much more
active rookie 12 d 7
rube t6
this first this first check the record
is six is not doing so much really okay
can I yeah this one so how to how to
minimize is come out to play maybe look
d3m this is good keeping this pawn and
he really has no good move again oh my
my points points of advance yeah okay i
can i can do that have two bonds check
black resigned Wow jump very intense
defense this is always a bit tricky it
looks like it's just a pawn but did you
need to be precise and he was certainly
okay again at some point yeah this is
this looks okay check and maybe maybe
here before here exactly here there is
need form there's need for precision
because of the c5 the c5 move
it's very difficult and the sum in this
situation with C 5v5 he has this d 4
square but the computer is just giving
the good solution here be five of course
oh yeah this is this is very good very
good yeah this is really excellent I
mean I even have Bishop c4 not right now
because of the CFR but it activates my
bishop so black will not take it would
go back and did this position I have I
have proper control over deform and can
just continue with normal moves King
situ or whatever 95 yeah this is this is
pretty much just a pawn I have this 95
roof which is very helpful yeah more
after that probably 95 I don't know this
wasn't it wasn't the great idea let's at
the end it's a very very shaky position
campy this was a point on I'd be five is
also good probably yeah this is better
okay but he took on c3 and now we got
the rook endgame and here it's really a
question he can play all kinds of moves
ooh k 2 and so on and this this is this
is slightly better for white unless he
plays f6 and this is the comp movie am I
mentioned this in the game already it
must play of 60 m this is the right one
and probably will lead to believe to it
wrong if i take then-rookie 6 covering
this and get
six here black is even better because of
the structure so we'll probably after f6
tech b6 and people will be a draw and
this now is just just a very composition
from white but this can easily happen
with the little time on the clock check
yeah he got into this trouble because of
a low clock time I think f6 is a move
that you would find with more time all
right interesting endgame thanks for
watching